إنه بعد ظهر يوم الأربعاء في غازيان تك،
أي بعد حوالي 60 ساعة من
وقوع الزلزال لأول مرة
صباح يوم الاثنين، وهذا هو المشهد في أحد
المباني التي انهارت بالكامل
هنا في الإبراهيميلي، هناك
عائلة كان
عمال الإنقاذ على
اتصال بها مدفونة  تحت هذا
المطاط، إنها إحدى قصص
الأمل وسط الكثير من حزن القلب هنا
وحول هذه المنطقة. كان رجل وأبناؤه
على اتصال
بفرق البحث والإنقاذ المحلية ومع
المتطوعين الذين يبذلون ما في وسعهم
للمساعدة في ضمان  أن أي شخص لا يزال على
قيد الحياة تحت الأنقاض يمكن انتشاله
في هذه المرحلة، لذلك هناك أمل في
الساعات القادمة في أن يتم إنقاذ هذه العائلة
ولكنها
مهمة صعبة حقًا وكانت الظروف الجوية
مريرة للغاية هنا
بقدر ما  الأرقام تشعر بالقلق جيدًا،
عشرة آلاف
قتيل،
وعشرات الآلاف من الجرحى في جميع أنحاء هذه
المنطقة، والآلاف من هؤلاء
يمكن أن يكونوا أطفالًا في هذا
المبنى وحده،
ونحن نعلم أنه كان هناك 15 شخصًا
كانوا بالفعل تحت الأنقاض ويحتاجون إلى
انتشالهم، وللأسف تم انتشال ثلاثة منهم بالفعل
ولكنهم فقدوا حياتهم،
بقيت هذه العائلة ويمكن أن يكون هناك
آخرون، وهذه قصة أمل
تنعكس في جميع أنحاء المنطقة وهذا أمر يثلج
الصدر، لكن
الصورة العامة هنا في تركيا وسوريا هي
صورة الدمار الهائل الذي خلفته بيكي أندرسون على
شبكة سي إن إن
لأنه في الداخل